[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant à madame
brigitte bourguignon présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales nos
débats en tête et serein pourtant depuis
je ne cesse de recevoir via réseaux
sociaux des insultes
un tantinet sexistes parfois mêmes
menaces de mort par guillotine
instruments barbare que je croyais banny
pourtant ce n'est pas ma conception du
débat démocratique
l'un de nos commissaires m'a rappelé en
commission que nous étions regarder
observer cela ne me gêne pas nos travaux
sont transparents et ne saurait donc
faire l'objet d'autres interprétations
je tiens simplement à dire de manière
très solennelle que je n'accepterai
jamais d'exercer mon mandat sous la
pression et les menaces de qui que ce
soit pour ma part je continuerai à
travailler
pour ma part je continuerai à travailler
et à présider cette commission en
faisant en sorte que ceux qui ont
d'autres avis que celui de la majorité
puisse l'exprimer de façon sereine
ouverte qui n'exclut donc en rien le
sourire merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]